auch wird der wissenschaft in letzter
zeit vorgeworfen fake news zu verbreiten
die vertrete dabei eigene interessen
oder würde gezielt eingesetzt werden um
die bevölkerung zu manipulieren
jetzt wurde ein fall veröffentlicht der
genau das zu legt eine these wird
aufgestellt die nur allzu gut gehen das
existierende meinungsbild passt aber es
ist tatsächlich lug und trug fake news
in der wissenschaft jetzt wirklich zum
kleinsten fiktion herzlich willkommen
wenn letzten videos von mir gesehen hat
der hat sicher ein wenig gemerkt wie
wichtig mir die prinzipien der
wissenschaft sind die es ermöglichen
zweifelsfreie erkenntnisse zu erlangen
den weg dorthin habe ich dem video zur
evolutionstheorie beschrieben aber auch
die wichtigste botschaft des
wissenschaftsjournalisten heißen die wir
bei tig zum veröffentlichen durften hat
das ja sehr gut erklärt es wird eine
hypothese aufgestellt dann wird sie vor
der veröffentlichung von
fachwissenschaftlern geprüft und dann
veröffentlicht dann ist es aber erstmal
nur eine hypothese die von weiteren
wissenschaftlern in weiteren
untersuchungen geprüft wird und dann
bestätigt oder eben auch widerlegt wird
und dabei gibt es immer wieder fälle in
denen gerade bei der veröffentlichung
der ersten hypothese mit einer ersten
studie oder einem experiment oder
ähnlichem gepfuscht und gefälscht wird
das ist wie bei und bieten das ist zwar
noch lange nicht den status einer
überprüften theorie erreicht aber es ist
schon wissenschaft und solche fälle
diskreditieren wie und das finde ich wie
büchern und im jetzigen fall braucht
auch noch nicht einmal eine weitere
wissenschaftliche studie die das
lügengebäude zum zusammensturz brachte
es ging sofort nach der veröffentlichung
los und dabei handelt es sich nicht um
irgendeine veröffentlichung sondern eine
in einer der renommiertesten
fachpublikationen in der fein so koloini
höhnstedt und der ökologie peter eckl
veröffentlichten eine studie die belegen
soll dass fisch laufen durch die
aufnahme von nico plattek ihr verhalten
ändern
doch die forscherin und der forscher
hatten wohl nicht redlich gearbeitet
kolleginnen und kollegen von der
forschungsstation auf der schwedischen
ostseeinsel gotland wo die studie
entstand wandten sich mit zahlreichen
vorwürfen an die universität uppsala
ihre vorwürfe waren gravierend die
ökologin und der ökologe hätten weniger
aquarien gearbeitet als in der studie
aufgeführten stadt wäre gar nicht lange
genug auf der insel gewesen um das
beschriebene experiment zu vollenden und
kann noch weitere punkte hinzu sie
hätten das mikro plastik zusammen mit
der suspension india qualen geschützt in
der die partikel geliefert worden seien
sie enthielten aber weitere chemikalien
so dass die wirkung des micro plastik
gar nicht von denen der anderen
chemikalien unterschieden werden
ja und so weiter das stellte das
zentrale schwedische gutachtergremium
cpm
bei der weiteren überprüfung der studie
fest sie kam zu einem vernichtenden
ergebnis die forschungsarbeit entspricht
nicht wissenschaftlichen standards sein
zog den artikels rückt damit reiht sich
die studie in die reihe weiterer
schlampiger arbeiten oder sogar
fälschungen 1
sei es der vom koreanischen tierarzt
wango zug erschaffene menschen klonen
die arbeiten das nanos riesiger wir
haben hendrik schön der messreihen
einfach gefälscht hatte oder der
berühmten im studio von android fehlt
die nachgewiesen haben wollte dass die
impfung gegen masern röteln und mumps
autismus hervorrufen würde in diesem
fall wurde die veröffentlichung nicht
nur zurückgezogen sondern im auto
entwickelt wurde auch die zulassung als
arzt entzogen weil er obwohl die studie
widerlegt worden ist diese these weiter
verbreitet und damit für zahlreiche
todesfälle verantwortlich ist ich finde
dass dieser fall der mikro plastik
studie ein tolles beispiel dafür ist wie
gut der wissenschaftsbetrieb
funktioniert keine hypothese die nicht
wirklich belegbar ist kann sich so lange
halten früher oder später wird sie von
jemandem entlarvt oder wenn die
wissenschaftlichen anforderungen genügt
widerlegt das einzige was also passieren
kann ist dass wir eine weile einer these
auf den leim gehen die nichts mit der
realität zu tun hat und wo wir wissen
dass alles wo zahlreiche forscher
beteiligt sind und sich ständig
gegenseitig überprüfen
zwangsläufig eine wahre erkenntnis ist
egal ob evolutionstheorie klimawandel
und so weiter er hat einen so komplexer
prozess stattgefunden
daran wird mit an sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit ausgeschlossen werden
kann
was heißt das für den
wissenschaftsjournalismus und für mich
hier bei pixum in der widerständige hier
auch spannende studien vor aber und das
ist genau davon ich sage deutlich dass
es eben studien sind ihnen noch
überprüft werden müssen oder das ist
erst mal eine these ist dass es nämlich
entscheiden dass wir als journalisten
hier wahrhaftig bleiben und somit auch
wissenschaftlich und ihr euch als
zuschauer verlassen können nicht dass er
eben alles genauso ist sondern eben
einordnen könnt ist es ein erster
hinweis eine vermutung eine studie ohne
überprüfung und so weiter und genau das
bekommt ihr hier und es
sehr gefreut als plötzlich jemand
kommentiert hat dass er ganz auf den
quellen hiernach gegangen ist oder das
thema wird gegoogelt hat und noch nie
etwas entdeckt hat das so nicht gestimmt
hat und sogar dass hier auch weiter
bleiben weitere videos zum thema fake
news wissenschaftliches arbeiten
forscher an die felsen und so weiter
wird es hier schon bald wieder geben
damit ihr nichts verpasst rücken wir
hier genau ein abo aus auge und vergesse
ich den auf die glocke und hier geht es
weiter mit dem video von jetzt heißen
zum gleichen thema mit der wichtigsten
botschaften seines lebens einfach
draufklicken bis dann platt